i am a really big harry potter fan it's
a good thing since over a decade of his
life was spent as ron weasley from the
laughs to the nerves to revisiting it
all years later we're covering the best
of rupert grint behind the scenes from
the very beginning before he even knew
how much this would change his life
people are gonna actually know my name
that's gonna be strange number one glitz
and glam isn't all it's cracked up to be
little rupert grint wasn't so keen on
his beautifying process in the makeup
chair being captured on tape rather not
be seen like this yeah because he
doesn't like the clip in his hair yeah
he was a fan of the performing the
barrettes not so much
number two it's time for some wizard
candy it's no surprise this scene was a
highlight to film i liked the train
scene because we got to eat loads of
sweets that was really cool the really
special part was that these sweets were
exactly as they were described in the
books and those birdie box beans it's
really heavy flavor there's vinegar
spinach
earwax egg all the excitement did become
a bit distracting and the actors wound
up having to film their bits in the
compartment separately we were never
actually really in the same compartment
we just couldn't look each other in the
eye and keep a straight face number
three it's hard for anyone to resist
let's be honest for rupert grint walking
into the great hall this is something we
can all agree on
was absolutely incredible all these
effects with all the candles
floating in the air all lit and
everything food on the table all the
flambos were lit it was just the most
amazing thing i've ever seen in my life
number four chess is kind of his thing
it was like sort of
turn in the limelight a definite
highlight in his first movie gig and he
slays it chess thing was pretty
difficult because there was loads of
dust everywhere and pieces were really
big i got to sit on my horse that was
really fun number five put an 11 year
old on a set what do you expect the
philosopher's stone set was the perfect
place to pull an innocent prank while
the hair laid is ethner she had this um
tape machine and um you could write out
what you want to say it'll come out like
a sticky tape kind of thing grunt didn't
resist the chance to have some fun
making a prank label kick me for one
pound fifty and we stuck it on the back
of robbie coltrane's back and then he
found out but no one knew it was us
number six he's a man of many talents
with all that down time on set the actor
got a bit creative i was just doodling
my quill in the book i drew this rather
unpretty picture of alan rickman and as
i was drawing it allen rickman was
standing right behind me and i was so
scared yikes thank goodness rickman was
a good sport about it and actually had
the young artiste signed it and
everything with snape it was really
scary number seven is he rupert is he
wrong who can tell the difference i
think i'm scared really like my
character i live in a family of
seven
and um i've got a redheaded sister and i
live in a borough slipping into the
character was simple from the start i've
always liked ron because i feel like i
can relate to him so i got red hair
scared of spiders we're both pretty
dodgy with a wand both like sweets
number eight be warned this is not for
the squeamish this was one of the
trickiest scenes for the actor in the
second movie you start to feel sick you
get on your hands and knees
i had this giant slug in my mouth loaded
with slime and i spat them out i think
it was plastic yeah we'd pass on this
one
number nine no rupert grinch were harmed
in the making of this scene the camera's
on the other hand i keep the camera on
my way into it accidentally prisoner of
azkaban brought about some very exciting
action the stunt thing i did that was
quite cool that was my favorite bits as
well getting dragged into the tree
luckily wasn't so traumatic on the
actual day i get dragged into this tree
by the dog it's basically a harness
strapped to my leg and this sort of like
big guy in a blue suit sort of like
pulling me into the tree it's really
sort of weird number 10 the harry potter
films being filled with spiders wasn't
so great for grant that was horrible
sharing this deep fear with his
character was not ideal but it came in
handy when it came to the acting yeah
i'm definitely afraid it's terrified
having to film with them so often well
that's when the struggle got real there
was going to be a scene where they were
going to dangle a spider on my shoulder
and so they did all these tests with
this little baby translator number
eleven was there ever a time grint
wasn't holding back laughter
there's hundreds and hundred examples of
this the actor's struggle was no secret
among the crew on set rupert finds
everything funny you'll ask him what we
laugh and he goes i don't know you can't
stop him once he starts and behind the
scenes you can bet the shenanigans
continued number 12 we wouldn't get in
the way of a fistful of weasley how
about you sometimes a line is just too
good do you want a fist full of weasley
it's an epic one but unfortunately i
found
hysterical
yeah they eventually got cut because i
couldn't say it sometimes a line is just
too good it's an epic one but
unfortunately it never came to be on
screen sorry
number 13. one one is in the building
those scenes were really good farming
jesse was was great grunt barely knew
actress jessie cave when they had to
film their steamy makeout scene it's
always quite an embarrassing thing
anyway kind of kissing in front of
everyone number 14. what can't rupert do
hi i'm rupert grint and this is the
stunts he warmed up he got rigged up he
became a quidditch keeper star in no
time fact is he never needed the liquid
luck number 15 make way for the
quidditch star it's probably about 20
feet high so it's
it's quite a long way down grint had
quite the experience getting to film a
more intense quidditch scene than he'd
ever done before and it didn't come
without struggle
it's just just sitting on a broom for
long periods of time just kind of after
a while kind of uh yeah it has a little
bit but he wasn't just sitting on any
old broom they took a mold from that
kind of area it definitely helped number
16 the trick to becoming ron is all in
the hips rupert grint had quite the
laugh watching dan mimick the way he
moved and spoke in the first deathly
hallows film kind of got all my posture
and everything down so what's the trick
to nailing this weasley it's actually
quite a sexy walk if you know if that's
appropriate to say number 17 please pass
the tissues asap the emotional scenes
with the wheezies because we lose one of
them it was quite quite an emotional
thing to film rupert grint felt the
struggle huddled around fred with his
weasley fam the heartbreak is real
number 18 just like kissing a sibling
there's the kiss which was
just quite um quite a strange one even
before filming the nerves were there
it's gonna be quite an awkward scene to
film i think especially the
kissing book the two actors being so
close in real life just made for weird
vibes on set it's like a sister a
brother-sister kind of relationship we
weren't really looking forward to it
really honestly and dan didn't help by
laughing through the whole process while
filming it's nice
wrong guess to go number 19 rupert
wasn't looking his best in the epilogue
of the final film i think ron kind of
ages probably the worst the process was
long and honestly not so pleasant to go
through the aging process was quite
quite weird on a dark just kind of
sitting in a makeup chair gradually
watching myself deteriorate
number 20 reunited and it feels so good
it's never really left me it's found so
many different new lives and
even the music can kind of stare for me
now that's an intense reaction honestly
we feel the same whenever we hear
hedwig's theme it was always important
for me to kind of figure out what i was
doing who i was so it's been nice to
have that time and i think this is the
perfect time to sit down with everyone
no matter how much time passes his
friends are always on his mind it's been
a long time since i've seen any of them
and but you know i think about those
movies all the time and i think about
down them a lot watching ron weasley and
rupert grint grow up was essentially the
same thing he's a gryffindor through and
through which behind the scenes moment
is your fave